the guy who claims they can do it all
and can't okay is a far less value than
the man who can look you in the eye and
say you know what I I know that I can do
this because I know that I can't do that
so I can tell you about any shadow of a
doubt because I know I can't do that I
know I can do this that's what the world
needs more of that's a real man so this
week and you can bring it up there uh
for those who didn't follow early I was
subject to my first auto accident as a
passenger I should say when I was a kid
I was hit by a car once oh yeah yeah
look at the whole dashboard just explode
with airbags those were not friendly
eyes by the way yeah was it blue on an
older Jeep we're exiting on a loop from
one freeway to another it's hard for me
to explain but basically here's a
freeway you need to get on this freeway
okay and there's a loop and the loop
comes running get on this freeway and
then there are only two lanes where
you're what and basically these two
lanes one lane is trying to get over on
the side of the freeway the freeway that
goes west and the other one people are
trying to get over on another loop that
goes downward going north south and I've
had to do this exit many times I've
always thought it was incredibly
dangerous so when the tire blew while we
were take obviously I panicked looking
at it now doesn't look so bad thank God
and it really was not as bad as it could
have been more fortunate than actually
ironically the complete spin out of the
car which could potentially increase the
force of the employment rented in the
concrete girder yeah I think caused it
to scrape a little bit which cradled
saved you a little bit the the crash I
mean the frame is totaled thank you John
Crete it was like oh yeah the frame is
completely well it's about a Jeep with a
metal bumper and Gompers completely
broken the metal deal frame completely
cracked bent so and she breaks my heart
because Johnny boy was driving loves
that sheet but it could have been a lot
worse thank God he's fine he'll get
another Jeep so I say this to explain to
you what happened and to let you know
that I understand that this isn't
exactly a straight with death as many
car accidents could be but at the time I
didn't know that so at that moment in
time feeling the tire blow out in one of
the most difficult loops in Texas all
Nuwas just pop spin screech and with
each spin I can just see two lanes
behind us the two lanes which one of
which is going very very fast and the
other people are coming in on a blind
loop and then spin spin spin concrete
garter spin spin spin girl
cars going by and it felt like they were
getting faster and then the concrete
girder was getting faster as it came
into view I thought it might be I really
thought it might be curtains in
retrospect no but it's kind of like that
kayak story that I've told you about
before I think of it where I was sure
that death yeah just like my parents
were gonna be on shore and just I
couldn't turn the kayak over it was one
of those old you know what the sealskin
is before not these open guys minutes
again yes especially have no idea just
had a cottage me I'm gonna go out the
smart design let's let's stick you
inside of a kayak and you can't get out
well they need to be watertight back in
the day yeah that's what that didn't
yeah but I I bring it up because
obviously I didn't die in a kayak I was
we didn't die in this car crash but at
that moment I thought this might be it
this is how it ends
and I I got that kind of flash at people
too I went into my life flash before my
eyes but let me explain it in this short
moment like count a million different
thoughts were going through my head
after it happened and I kind of got to
download I was going I think of all
these things at that second so first off
was obviously my god just please
straighten out and then I thought this
exit is the worst and I remember
thinking this is that like damnit this
exit is the worst city engineering in
history and then I thought I'm never
traveling in an old Jeep with crappy
felt seats again and then I thought okay
we're definitely spinning out and then I
thought God just please let us crash
them or not into these two lanes and I
thought oh my god we're gonna crash and
now I just really hoped in other car
doesn't come and hit us and then it hit
me okay I could I could die right here
remember that thought going through my
head this could happen is be and the odd
thing is I was oddly accepting of it and
sometimes in those moments it's it's
kind of a silly but perfect example of
ego you try to almost strike a bargain
with God and I remember thinking you
know what in this month this really in
this moment I'm everything death would
be okay I just don't want to get hurt
so let me die that's fine but just don't
let me be crippled or May
door pried out with the jaws of life on
a nightly news in a quadrant view and
then there was the moment when the the
airbags went off and these are mid-90s
airbags not they were certainly not soft
it wasn't like being cradled and your
loves bosoms at all these were decidedly
unfriendly aggressive airbags they went
off causing my head - what I can only
imagine was like getting paddled back
and forth between the unsupportive
bucket seats like a pinball just and I
couldn't hear anything
everything went completely white things
slowly kind of came back into view and
sounds warped back in smoke was coming
out of the - I think was the airbag gas
I don't know I've never had airbags
deployed before certainly not in the I
don't know it's a 90s model cheap I
think it was total sensory deprivation
and I couldn't really move when I came
to and there was a moment there where I
thought oh crap I'm still here but I
can't move cars are coming they're gonna
hit us and then I thought oh crap I'm
still here I don't know how bad this is
going to be and I can't move and we're
being upset about it and thinking about
it now it's pretty disgusting I'm pretty
disgusted I thought that and sometimes
there are aspects of yourself that you
can't really fully understand until
you're put in that kind of a scenario
but isn't that the way it often goes in
life many times will do anything just to
avoid the pain sometimes we'd rather
take the loss the finality of defeat or
in this case I'll take death instead of
being in a wheelchair it sounds silly
but I remember thinking that will take
that finality rather than the pain of
the struggle and I think I know why at
least in my case and trying to
deconstruct some of this because I had
afterward there was a lot of it's a
cornucopia of adrenaline induced
visceral a mode of reactions and many of
you watching this show know that I'm not
a big fan of cliches not the Oprah
friendly sound bites but usually because
they're often untrue and in this case
one that comes to mind we hear a lot is
people aren't afraid of being powerless
there they're more afraid of being more
powerful and they can possibly imagine
something like neither one of those
things is true no one wants to be
powerless and I can attest to in that
moment in time sort of I was trying to
control aspects of the uncontrollable
but I think the reason that many of us
will find the
look for it take the defeat over the
pain of the struggle is because we all
find comfort in the idea that our
limitations are burdens or even our
ultimate defeats are completely out of
our control right if I if I remember
that if I die I die that it's just my
time that's out of my hands but if I
don't the balls back in my court if I
don't die this might hurt a lot and I
have to go through a really tough climb
just to get back to capable and it's an
even harder pill to swallow that
sometimes we feel the setback is out of
our control but the recovery is on us
and that's a lot to take that's hard
that's life and you know what that never
changes I'm gonna give you another
example from from this crash that will
hopefully explain it um
again to explain a lot of the crap to
unpack that I'm not proud of as it
relates to ego right after the accident
my friend Johnny boy was driving was
shaking like hey my vitals were fine his
blood pressure was was through the roof
I could tell he was out of it and in the
past hope it isn't mind me sharing this
like I asked him before he I know that
he has had absence seizures when he was
young so I was very worried about him
because he was shaking so our wives Tim
and Manny who work with us they're
fantastic they they came and got us off
the freeway went to a nearby McDonald's
right away I said Johnny has to go home
send him home and remember telling my
wife and the team that I was pretty much
fine and I just needed a moment to
gather my bearings it was a lie I lied I
did not feel fine and I said to them
that I thought I could still go down to
the AIDS Walk and do the whole day of
filming I said I just needed a minute it
reminds me of that scene and if you ever
saw the film regarding Henry did you
ever see regarding Henry yeah it's where
Harrison Ford gets shot and I think it's
the most accurate depiction of the kind
of shock in that scenario ever put on
screen maybe along with captain Phillips
that was really good too but Harrison
Ford is that a committee stroke getting
a pack of smokes and a guy holding up a
store he just demands his wallet and
shoots him and Harrison Ford and he
doesn't spin over like a in a spaghetti
western or he doesn't scream in pain he
just holds up his hand and he you know
Harrison Ford's and only whoa wait a
minute wait a minute he's just holding
oh hold on hold on a minute he falls
over and shock and he's bleeding he was
shot and it's almost more impactful when
you watch this because you think that's
probably how someone might react dad's
how I felt at the McDonald's at that
point I was saying I'm fine I just need
to take a second but the adrenaline dump
stopped
and I'm pretty sure the airbag boxed my
right ear because I couldn't hear all
day it was it was ringing just increase
of that yeah high-pitched ringing like
in Saving Private Ryan I couldn't hear
out am i right here for the rest of the
day and that was my equivalent said well
hold on a minute I was sore I was tired
I couldn't hear I didn't feel fine you
know why I lied because of you go I was
thinking of the people depending on me
the people that we employ here the idea
that this story would circulate and that
they would maybe say oh man you know
Steven was such a such a trooper he went
on down he finished a segment anyway and
so I lied and I said it was fine but
remember when I was saying it I was
looking to my wife and I think we've all
done this at some point was looking at
my wife with the eye saying I'm not fine
I'm not fine step in here call it don't
let me go because I wanted to prove that
I could do it
but if my wife said no you're going home
well guys that's that's out of my that's
out of my hands
I see the point here is I realize that I
wanted my limitations to be set by
someone else I wanted my defeat or what
I perceived is my defeat to be out of my
control because otherwise people would
see me as a quitter the truth is in not
being honest in lying to myself and my
team about what I could or couldn't
control that was in a way that was more
of quitting what would have been less of
a quitters mentality would have been to
say guys I can't hear you my neck hurts
I'm tired I'm going home we'll live to
fight another day because that would
have been taking ownership the situation
myself but instead I just wanted to say
no no I can do it I can do this and I
was looking for anyone else anyone else
to take the out for me and that's the
mentality of wanting to absolve myself
the responsibility of accepting and
recognizing my own limitations and I was
I was doing it all over again just like
the crash the the bargain with God if
you wanna cut hey if I if I die that's
fine that's on you just please don't let
me live and be a vegetable because
that's on me and that's gonna suck and
it'll be embarrassing
in this scenario saying hey if my wife
calls it if one of you calls it that's
on you there's nothing I can do if you
don't it's on me and I'm gonna have to
grit my teeth and bear it and it being
on me it's hard because that means now
I've got a decision to make a decision
to recognize my limitations and chart a
realistic course of action to recognize
what I could not do now here's the
here's nothing Manny and Tim they
decided to call it they said no you're
going home because they're good people
and I'll tell you I felt relief but that
doesn't change that I was lying to
myself they didn't decide for me I let
them decide for me because through ego I
basically abandoned my post so my
challenge to you is this think of how
often you do this particularly the young
men out there how often do you look for
a reason to lie to yourself to present
this facade of things being out of your
control just to avoid admitting your
weaknesses have you done it like well
you know I guarantee you have I
guarantee you'll do it this week could
be as severe as what I went through or
much more severe than wet or it could be
as simple as up you know I was I was
late traffic on the freeway it's out of
my hands there's nothing I can do is it
do you often find yourself running late
are you really Superman do you make
promises you can't keep why and what I
want you to do is rather than wait until
a crisis occurs so you can throw up your
hands and chalk it up to being out of
your control I want you to take
inventory right now what are your
limitations what are your weaknesses
your quiet time take a minute take
inventory because guess what it's okay
it's okay of limitations it's okay to
have weaknesses it's okay to be honest
about them this is where we get it wrong
it's not okay to celebrate them we don't
need to celebrate our weaknesses but
it's good to work on them and there are
many things in life that we can't
control
but I think we all want to bear a little
less responsibility than we probably
should sometimes here's something you
can control you can control right now
recognizing your weaknesses recognizing
your limitations and accepting the
incremental improvements that you can
make to correct them but you can you can
never know what that is this is
something - we'll talk about this a lot
with with knowing what the hard door is
knowing what the easy out is in
recognizing you can never know you will
never know what your potential is what
you're capable of truly accomplishing if
you're lying to yourself because of ego
the guy who claims you can do it all and
can't okay is a far less value than the
man who can look you in the eye and say
you know what I I know that I can do
this because I know that I can't do that
so I can tell you about any shadow of a
doubt because I know I can't do that I
know I can do this that's what the world
needs
more of that's a real man hey there if
you like this video subscribe to the
channel or hit the notification Bell do
it I'll wait a second
do your that little ding it actually
didn't make a ding sound I just did it
happen while my mouth was doing it and
you thought it was coming from your
computer so that's fun also there's some
videos playing in these boxes next to me
go watch those you might enjoy them you
might not you don't care